Hello, I'm Patti Brennan director of the National
Library of Medicine and I'm here to talk to you
today about the NIH research and education program
that we have underway here at the National Library
of Medicine this special program referred to as
an r25 training program introduces promising young
scholars undergraduates and graduate students
to the field of biomedical informatics and data
science biomedical informatics and data
science is the fundamental core of how we
will discover Truth for health over the next
50 years the goal of the National Library of
medicine's R-25 program is to support educational
activities that encourage talented undergraduate
and master students including those from
groups underrepresented in the biomedical
Behavioral Sciences to pursue further training and
careers in biomedical informatics and data science
I am most excited to see this Innovative program
launched at the National Library of Medicine it's
frankly the most exciting thing I've seen
in the last five years [Applause] [Music]
thank you
as one of the 27 institutes at NIH the
National Library of Medicine supports
Innovative research and development and
biomedical informatics and data science
through the new r25 program nlm is developing a
new generation of scientists capable of leading
biomedical informatics and data
science research into the future
this summer 12 universities are participating in
the inaugural cycle of the program we are super
excited to be one of the 12 institutions uh being
funded through the National Library of Medicine
for this training and experiential learning in
biomedical informatics we all know that it's very
important for the next generation of investigators
to be exposed to a wide variety of disciplines
they need a foundation in training and experience
in both life and physical sciences as well as
computational mathematical engineering informatics
like many things associated with Computing science
is accelerating exponentially so almost any
scientific field these days involves this big
data generation and now we started developing this
complex AI machine learning methods to combine Big
Data with these with these Technologies so these
training programs I think provide a foundational
experiences for for young people and help them see
the utility of informatics algorithms techniques
and protocols and give them an idea of what can be
accomplished and also ground them in doing it with
you know proper scientific and statistical rigor
the NIH encourages all institutions to diversify
their student and faculty populations to enhance
the participation of individuals from diverse
groups including those nationally underrepresented
in biomedical Clinical and Behavioral and social
science research in addition the NIH encourages
individuals to identify with different racial
and ethnic groups as well as those from socially
and economically disadvantaged backgrounds and
individuals with disabilities to consider a career
in biomedical sciences and biomedical informatics
when you look at the composition of the workforce
in stem in general but let's just say biomedical
informatics it is clear that we don't have a
diversified Workforce to meet the advances of the
21st century when Dr Boyce and I were trying to
set up a program we were trying to count how many
deaf and hard of hearing students with biomedical
informatics or bioinformatics have a degree
you could just count it on your fingers so the
overall message is to bring diversity in the field
through foundational skills building
and mentorship the nlm r25 program is
strengthening a diverse NIH supported Workforce
that will Foster scientific innovation enhance
Global competitiveness and improve the quality
of research my dream job is to bridge Healthcare
Systems along with health informatics especially
coming from a place where you get to see
Health determine its affect the health risks in
today's world a lot of it comes from environmental
factors external factors and that's something I
want to bring more advocacy to especially using
health informatics for me to have those skills
especially being a female I believe that you can
Bridge Hands-On health care experience and then
the world of data science and technology and
that's something that I would like to take part in
part of making data available to so many different
audiences is really building that scaffolding that
infrastructure for people to find data and then
ultimately make use of it MLM has been involved in
Data before data science was even really a term we
have the national Center for biotechnology
information which is a really incredible
data resource for people that are working with
biomedical data of all different types and we have
a lot of other resources that we make available
like PubMed to provide access to the literature so
really we have been involved in making information
and data available to people for a long time
a lot of these tools that are we're going
to be teaching them you know how to look
for genomic sequences or how to do you know
data visualization or things like that those
are the tools and skills that are required by
the market and I think by giving them through
this program and also you know especially since
it's from the National Library of Medicine where
we use a lot of their Tools in our classrooms
I think it will be very good for them to kind
of get exposure to some in-depth skills that
are required by the field now who are in this
in this Mission from us we have computerized
clinical records and all of these different
data sources that if we could combine
them and figure out you know what are
the best forms of analysis we can really
accelerate the speed of biomedical discovery
so we're talking about artificial intelligence
machine learning natural language processing all
of these ways of collecting analyzing data we need
to have the prepared Workforce each student will
have a research faculty mentor to work one-on-one
this is very very important because many times you
start a graduate level career and you take courses
but it takes a while until you find the right
mentor and you have so many faculty that you're
going to be exposed to and you know that that
individual that you identify were food identifies
you it's going to be extremely important not only
for your graduate career but also as you move into
your career further I owe everything I am to my
mentors today my you know especially my scientific
career I myself have trained over 150 people and
they all keep in touch with me and I'm so happy to
see them really do well when they go into you know
top positions and they get tenure track positions
or they start their own companies so to me that
is the most rewarding aspect of it is the human
interaction paying what was paid to me forward to
all these students the impact of this program I
see it as going far beyond education and career
decision of the students that will participate
it will really create that awareness that's so
needed in biomedical informatics in public health
informatics and data science it it will really
emphasize and take advantage of the great spirit
of information sharing that it's so needed today